everybody thanks for joining i am super
excited and happy to have this great
turnout
um so uh i don't want to eat too much
into our speaker's time because
uh i think what they have to say can be
really exciting and interesting
um i i'm on the kiss i'm on the customer
success team
um at our studio which means that i work
with our enterprise customers
to help them leverage their r studio
tooling um and make the most out of
their investment
um i've i've been working um
predominantly
with teams in the last year and a half
um in the manufacturing and consumer
products space
and um i think it's an interesting space
to be in
and and what i've noticed is whether
you're
creating um whether you're creating
large machinery or airplanes or if
you're
creating you know little widgets
um the problems and the challenges in
the use case
are all similar um in this space
and so what what i'm hoping today is
that uh you'll hear from these three
different champions in the organization
and and hear that the types of problems
that they're solving and the challenges
that they're facing
um i hope they'll resonate with what you
might be encountering in your day-to-day
and i'm i'm hoping that we can continue
this dialogue with the community site um
have some great questions and
discussions
following today um and and make this an
ongoing
and regular um group where we can
connect and network and ask questions of
one another so
um with that um i want to first uh
kick off over to brenden scully um from
pratt
um brendan is a citizen analytics
strategy lead for pratt whitney's
aftermarket business operations um i'm
excited to have him
launch us off brenton do you wanna get
going
awesome thanks for the intro katie um i
just shared my screen
um can i just get one confirmation that
it's coming through
it looks awesome yep we got it
great um then yeah
i'll start with an introduction of
myself i've been at pratt whitney for a
relatively short time about one and a
half years now
i was hired initially as a contractor so
through a contracting agency to develop
a forecasting model
and from there transitioned to a role on
the strategy team
where my current focus is on the
strategy
side of decision analytics at pratt
whitney
in this presentation i'm going to
overview
provide an overview of two of the tools
that i developed at prep using r
and r studio connect and then
uh go into a few of the lessons learned
in my
strategy role that you know apply of
course directly to pratt but
i'm sure apply broadly to other large
companies as well
[Music]
so starting off the first tool i'm going
to talk about is an engine repair
forecasting model this is the
first tool that i worked on at pratt
and a brief background of pratt whitney
for those of you not familiar
according to wikipedia bratton whitney
is an aerospace manufacturer with global
service operations
uh and you know what that means is we
manufacture and repair military
and commercial engines and my role
throughout my whole time at brat has
been focused on the commercial
aftermarket side of the business which
includes
maintenance repair and overhaul of all
of our engines
so one of the biggest questions that we
focus on on this side of the company
is how many engines can our global
network of repair shops
repair in the upcoming year
this question is important because the
repair shops are giving annual and
monthly repair goals that their
performance is evaluated against
and throughout this planning process
any shortfalls that are identified then
lead to
a lot of the work that goes on
throughout the year from
investing in new repair technology
capacity constraints and making
decisions to reallocate engines across
the network
uh this question is also a complex
question
repair performance and the number of
engines that
our entire network can repair is
influenced by
many interacting variables such as the
type of repair being performed
the turnaround time of each individual
repair
the capacity not only at the shops
themselves but within
the different sections of each shot
and existing work progress and backlogs
so not an easy question to answer using
the current state i guess before i move
on to the solution
um the current state that was in place
to answer this question was largely done
by taking
the previous year's numbers and
increasing and decreasing that amount
based on
knowledge of changes in the business
conversations with the general managers
at all the repair shops
uh what lacked was a quantified a
rigorous quantified justification behind
these numbers
um and so what pratt wanted was to make
an answer to this question more robust
and defendable
by giving it a quantified justification
so the solution that i developed that
helps
answer this question is a
simulation based forecasting model using
r
that has been hosted on our studio
connect so what this model does
is it takes our global network of repair
shops
and models the flow of engines from the
wing of the airplane
through each stage of the repair journey
all the way through the delivery to
customer
using a markov decision process so
the diagram on the right i know the text
is small and it's not really meant to be
read
but it shows how the process is
you know mapped out at a high level
where each stage of the repair journey
is given
a state and then um the
flow from of the engines from state to
state is in governed
by rules um and those rules
are all dependent on uh a large number
of inputs
from the turnaround times to the
capacity of the shops
to the work in progress to the induction
plan
to the engines currently sitting outside
the shop in backlog
and so uh what what that one thing this
model
allows pratt to do now is instead of
you know talking about as a whole and
doing all that thinking in your head
we can have focused conversations on
individual inputs like the capacity of
this section of the shop has that
increased or decreased
uh the turnaround times are we expecting
similar turnover attempts on these
repairs this year
as opposed to next year and then roll
all of those
inputs and conversations um up to
the model which will then output
a final number for engines inducted and
returned
so benefit is the main benefit is it
offers a quantified justification for
annual monthly repair goals
and then it also allows for sensitivity
analysis
sensitivity analysis and scenario
testing
um this has taken the shape of
how does increasing the capacity of this
shop actually impact the number of
engines we get to repair as a whole
or scenario testing which came into play
last year as kovid hit the airline
industry
we had to rapidly change our goals and
adapt to
you know a new environment new demand
and
new capacity as a lot of our workforce
was reduced
and so this model quickly allowed us to
run
many different scenarios in a short
period of time
which is something we weren't able to do
before the last benefit
is having the graphical user interface
on rstudio
so that ultimately i'm not the end user
of this model
and the end user of this model
doesn't have strong background in r and
can operate and use the model through
our studio connect and the graphic user
um a few screenshots to show you what it
looks like and what that interface is
like i'll highlight a few things here
and these are four of the main screens
uh the only thing not shown here
is the ability to then download the raw
data output for
you know any analysis that isn't
displayed here but these four screens
answer most of the common questions that
pratt is interested in
namely what are the inductions
what are the annual inductions into our
repair shops and what are the annual
returns
what's the comparison to plan
um and where there is backlog
there's a page that then drills down and
shows each individual engine that's
being modeled
where the backlog occurred and what
could be done to address it
the next tool that i'm going to talk
about is a whip management tool
whip stands for work in progress and
it's the term we use
to describe
the engines currently in a repair shop
so
this model came about
from or this this project came about
from conversations with one of our
specific repair shops um when an
engine is received a repair shop signs a
contract
with a promise date at which the engine
will be returned
to the customer and the biggest issue at
this shop
was late deliveries uh their number one
customer complaint
was that promise dates couldn't be
trusted and this impacted their brand
and so their question their their
problem to me was how can the number of
late deliveries
that is repair is taking longer than
promised the customer
be reduced um
i talked a little bit about the
importance of this
uh but when an engine is not delivered
to the customer on the date that they
promised
it's difficult for the customers to plan
their business operations
and they've they've told this shop many
times listen it's
okay if the promise date is later but we
just need to know a date so we can plan
our operations
so that was one of the big important
parts of this question
the other one is of course as we as
pratt misses delivery dates
um negative impact uh it leads to
negative impact on our brand and
reputation which
impacts our ability to win new contracts
the other important part of this
question is
the issue that the shop faced was
inefficient
prioritization of their work in progress
because
with the backlog that they had they
found themselves
focusing on parts and repairs for
customers that simply screamed the
loudest
which was described as a chaotic
business process
and so the fundamental issue here was a
lack of visibility
for a complete view or understanding of
what was in the shop at any given time
it required a manual pull from different
databases
and a manual report build and because of
the labor and time-consuming
nature of this process it was done once
a day
and there there still wasn't full
visibility
onto uh what engines were what what
parts
were on hold with the engineering team
without
going around and you know investigating
on an engine by engine basis
the other issue that led to this problem
was uh there was no measure of repairs
expected
delivery date um aside from
intuition and judgment um knowing where
in the shop
each part was uh there was no quantified
metric for
a repairs expected delivery date
so the solution developed here was a
whip overview dashboard and forecasted
repair completion date model
what this dashboard did is it
takes real time work in progress
progress so the real-time repair
progress
and hold data and it aggregates it and
displays it on a dashboard
so fundamentally this is just a
dashboard that displays
the current state of the shop
it takes it has one analytical layer to
it that takes historical repair data
and uses that to estimate turnaround
times
and likelihoods of on-time delivery for
current repairs
so one example here is a fan blade comes
into the shop
well that sand blade with that type of
damage has been in the shop
50 times before and this chart here
shows the actual historical turnaround
times
of you know part and repair number
a25343 so a repair that's been to the
shop many times
and we have a good idea of what the
range of turnaround times are
so it uses that distribution then to
give an expected turnaround time an
expected delivery date
and then the likelihood that it'll be
delivered on time
some screenshots from this tool um i'll
highlight a few things here
um the the forward pane here that has
those four boxes that gives the
direct overview in green on the right
how many
engines how many repairs are in the shop
right now
how many of them are on hold so how many
of them cannot be touched
uh because they're waiting for input
from the customer or our engineering
team
and then how many have missed the
delivery date an important feature here
is the what is the bar chart or the
histogram you see there
um an interesting trend that this
makes clear and highlights is
how at the end of each month there's a
surge
in uh repairs that are due
so that first tall bar happens to be the
last date of august when this screenshot
was taken
and what this does is it gives a you
know right up front it gives the
repair shop general manager and the cell
leads a clear view of what's coming down
the pipeline
and just that visibility alone helps
drive
the prioritization and the behavior
needed to minimize those
missed delivery dates
also included in this tool in the second
pane here
is a drill down into the individual
repairs where information can be seen on
their progress
so moving on to uh you know the
my role in the strategy team is i've
kind of taken a step back from the
individual tools
and taken a higher level view and
trying to work on ways that pratt can
prioritize decision analytics projects
and best use them
and one framework that's helped me think
about these projects is the decision
analytics
hierarchy of needs based loosely off
maslow's hierarchy of needs the idea
here
being each uh each level of the pyramid
needs to be addressed before the other
one can even be worked on
and the the way i've broken it down and
the way i see a lot of projects at pratt
are data storage um
data storage and organization is the
first step and the most important step
that needs to be addressed
data relevant to your project
or your business need needs to be stored
and organized
in an effective and thoughtful way
however storage and organization is not
enough there then needs to be
um data accessibility in place so what's
required to make the data accessible to
stakeholders
that could be literal access um
access approval um having the
credentials or tools needed to access
the database
but it also means is it stored in a way
that is accessible
is it in there's there's a team here
that has
a lot of repaired information stored in
pdfs well it's stored but it's not
accessible in a meaningful way
the last step then is when you have
successful data storage and
accessibility uh is then
building the analytics tools and then
implementing
data-driven decisions so how can the
data then be used to serve our needs and
make better decisions
a lot of times there's a lot of talk and
focus on the top of the pyramid without
full understanding and focus on data
accessibility and data storage
so this is a framework that i find
useful to
level set expectations for a project and
then
direct the right resources to the right
problems before starting a project
and then this last slide here are some
common challenges that i
faced during my time at pratt um and i'm
sure are not specific to pratt
uh i also talk about um
some of the approaches that uh you know
we've taken here
to address these issues they're by no
means the right answer or
even the the only right answer or even
complete answers to the problems but
they
are steps that we've taken that have
helped us
so one of the biggest common challenges
is lack of engagement from all
stakeholders
and i see him running a bit short on
time so i will
rattle through this somewhat quickly but
there's two main cases that
that we've identified or i've noticed
here
and that's analytics tools developed
without enough input from the end user
this usually means or results in the
business needs not being addressed by
the tool directly
and ultimate ownership and integration
of the tool into business processes
becomes unclear and difficult
the other the other type of issue of
lack of engagement from all stakeholders
is analytics tools being developed by
the business users and in our case the
repair shops
without involvement of the central
technology team
um this usually leads to fragile and
fragmented architecture
manual data transfer copying of excel
files and csv files
and an inefficient use of resources
two ways that we've addressed this and
we are working to address these issues
are to involve the business user more
for both of these you need to approach
these problems and these situations with
the intention of bringing the
stakeholders together
to involve a business user more the
design needs to be centered around the
business need
um then effort needs to be put
in to develop and implement a minimum
viable product
and then iterate and increase investment
over time
uh all the while incorporating feedback
to meet the business need
um finally the uh
or secondly to
encourage the business users to involve
the digital technology team
regular communications to understand
business needs and capabilities should
be established we did this in the form
of
phone calls all our repair sites to
understand their needs and talk about
our capabilities
and then the big thing here is organic
involvement of the digital technology
digital technology team through a series
of successes
so have the business users organically
come to the digital technology team
because you've delivered value in the
past
the last issue is one that
you know they're i'm sure many
organizations face most inefficient
allocation of limited resources so
there's limited funding
and limited hours in the day um
the obvious answer here that you know
has existed but sometimes isn't always
used here at pratt is developing
prioritization methodologies
that's taking a step back clearly
defining strategic organizational goals
and then designing a resource allocation
process
that stimulates and promotes
conversation
on how these projects align to the
strategic organizational goals
all right um i will stop there and
pause for any questions i hope i didn't
go over time
oh you were you were great brendan thank
you
i do know we have quite a bit to go
through for
an hour so i may put some of the
questions to the chat window initially
if that's okay
for brendan i know one question
jeff just asked is for data storage what
question
what solutions or technologies are you
currently using
if you wouldn't mind answering that one
in the chat too
totally uh oh answer in the chat or
answer it or we can answer that one
quickly now
okay answer that one quickly and then
other ones in the chat but
data storage um the biggest tool that we
use is sap
and uh that has all of our repair data
um and really all the data that's needed
uh most of the data is needed to build
these tools
the one interesting thing i'll comment
on that is sap is set up
for us at least in a way that it is
you know all the resources sap are used
to store the data
and you can't connect directly to sap so
we've developed
other database tools that for the sole
purpose of
bringing the data from sap on a periodic
basis
and then making that as an oracle
database hadoop as another tool that
we've used
to connect directly to the data
the big reason there is it's resource
intensive to pull from sap
so you have one tool that does that and
then that becomes the source
for a lot of other tools awesome
thank you so much brendan for our
second presentation i'd love to turn it
over to
philip lear as well so philip is a
principal data scientist at the kellogg
company
and i think i may need to end your share
there brendan
there we go and i think phil you should
be able to share now
and again please ask any questions uh
through the chat too
and we'll follow up with the presenters
after and i'll put that on
community too thanks phil
can you can you see my screen and are
you seeing the
the right presentation so i'm using
multiple monitors and i always get
confused yes why didn't you see what i
see okay
we can see it so like i said i'm the
principal data scientist
at the kellogg company um i
assume most people are fairly familiar
with kellogg but
um just as a brief history we are a 115
year old food company
um the slide kind of shows the timeline
what i'd like to get out of this is that
on the left you sort of see these
great brands and historic development of
sales and marketing techniques and all
that that is sort of like
the first part of kellogg's history
most of this probably took place before
there were i.t departments or
you know certainly analytic departments
but in the middle
you start to see um where i t
start you know what where rit and
analytics just play an important role
so the 70s we acquire a frozen waffle
company it's
very different than than shelf stable
cereal 2000 we acquire kashi this is an
entirely different supply chain because
it's natural and organic
new set of customers 2001 we acquire
keebler
which is a giant snacks company in its
own right they actually use something
called
direct store delivery as their
distribution model
which means the employees who are the
people who drive the trucks and the
trucks are assets and the
logistics are managed so the amount of
data generated by
a keeler cookie from factory to the
store shelf is significantly more than a
box of
frosted flakes would have we actually
had to adopt keebler's
erp system because what calicon at the
time could handle it
pringles is a massive global supply
chain
um in 2015 we expanded to africa and
egypt with major brands
2017 rx bars acquired which is a new set
of customers and
and primarily through e-commerce and
then in 2019 we actually spun
off the cookie and fruit snacks and
ingredients business
of keebler into and sold it to ferrero
my hypothesis would be that the right
side is sort of enabled by
by it and analytics but it's still 115
year old company
and there were still a number of
challenges we've had i started in 2010
um for if you need some reference
tick-tock by casualist the number one
song i honestly don't think i know any
of these
songs i was surprised when i looked
these up
but our ecosystem at kellogg for
analytics
and keep in mind we have sap we have all
these other things
the you know the reporting
at the company was was well established
but analytics was sort of
niche everything was sort of segmented
it had its own thing analytics primarily
in the business either marketing or
sales
we had our own network of servers which
by that i mean we had desktop set set
under our desks
and had raid drives attached to them and
if a
hard drive or a fan failed on one of
these raid drives
um there were more more than one
occasion i actually went to best buy
to go buy a new hard drive we had a
little tool box and you know we unscrew
the plates and pull the drives out
it's very very very very sort of you
know gorilla analytics team
at the time um desktop sas license
um desktop r and python obviously
we could not touch sap at all so any
data we
needed to get from sap traditionally had
to go into a transfer server
and then it was sort of like this rube
goldberg machine of how to get data from
one place to the next
and then probably the worst part to me
coming out of grad school was
everything that was a deliverable was
effectively in
excel or python or excel or powerpoint
sorry
and i was an econ grad i i hadn't really
ever used
either one of those to be completely
honest so
in the first few years of my time at
kellogg
i think i wrote more vba code
um than most people probably would ever
write in a lifetime because they'd want
simulations and some of these other
things
the downside of all that was that if you
build a tool in excel
and you gave it to somebody there was
zero chance of ever updating
any of the data or any of the methods or
anything in those tools
so over the next few years we really
focused
on how we got data
and how we delivered sort of these
data products to people um
if anyone who i work with is watching
this there they may disagree with how
nice and neat these lines look but it
was certainly an improvement over
you know what we had when we started we
moved to a sas server
which you know effectively let people
you know share code and
compute time and all these things across
the network we had sharepoint to sort of
deliver powerpoint and excels to people
versus
you know sending mass emails this helps
a little and that we could
replace a version on sharepoint but
obviously if someone
copies you know takes a copy there's no
way to update that
um we got a tableau server which i think
reduced some of the power points
but um you know
people were stretching the limits of
tableau and what it could do
so we we stood up some net servers where
people could build custom applications
and tie them in to
you know serve short procedures could
act on databases or you could run a sas
store procedure
and sort of do these things but there's
a fair amount of
um bureaucracy you'd have to go through
to get through these
so in 2018 there was a
push that i think the
what people said is cloud first mobile
first api first was sort of uh
an it rallying cry the majority of the
analytics people had been moved into
i.t by this time
you know we had multiple servers we
stood up a number of uh database
management systems that people could
access depending upon the level of skill
they needed access to
and in 2018 i i was just sort of sent
on endless amounts of conferences as we
approached building the strategy there
are a lot of them that were
you know less valuable than than others
just by happenstance in 2018 there's
this conference called earl which is the
enterprise application of the r language
apparently it's not normally in the us
so this is sort of a special occasion
and i grabbed a couple people on the
team
and we went to this and
i loved it i mean it was awesome to hear
people
talking about using you know r and open
source sort of
in a production environment in an
enterprise environment
i think our studio had a small table
there and it was thomas mock actually i
remember this
and um whoever he was with he got
grilled for like two hours by me
and an engineer i brought and one of the
other people on our team
on what connect did because we're
effectively going
through the idea of like what we were
building
to deliver this cloud-based architecture
for analytics
um a couple months later our studio
confis
is in austin we go to that as well um
and again
thomas mock is there and i accost him
and talk to him
and i you know i told him i was actually
skipping i i
teach at university future honors class
the econ students
effectively teach them how to use r in
sort of real world applications for
econometrics
and i told you i'm skipping this and i
was teaching
so they got a week off but i was going
to come back and you know share all this
with them
and he told me about our studio cloud
which was in beta at the time
so i went back you know so end of
january i go back i start teaching and i
attempt to switch
all of these you know juniors and
seniors
on to using a cloud platform or these
are these are college kids they
they don't really know if they're
they're econ major college kids they
don't really know much about this stuff
so i had sort of one experiment going
with this cloud-based
analytics with my students and then we
came back we started
really looking into things prior to this
we
you know we looked at the usual suspects
the anacondas
and you know i think one of our
one of our engineers built um
zeppelin which is apache sort of version
of a notebook but it's based on
the java runtime environment i think
this is the first time i ever saw
someone sort of get booed
when they presented something because
the you know the
data scientists at the time didn't
really want to
learn java to you know to run there
there are notebooks so
what we go through now is sort of uh
story in three acts
two parts each act three things we did
well and then
three things we could have done better
so the first thing we did is set up
these test environments
like i said we we tried multiple
environments we i think we you know
somehow
provisioned some servers and started
setting all these little tests up and
doing things
because we were having a conversation
with a t which is
a fair amount of i.t people are like
finance managers program managers
everyone was very very interested in
switching open source which was very odd
to me because i started and i
you know i talked about r python um
most of the time people thought there
was some security risks using open
source
open source software but somewhere along
the line there is a change of heart i
come to find out
this is mostly because they thought open
source meant free like they thought that
switching to r would mean like total
cost of ownership would go
you know would go down substantially and
it was very difficult to say
you know to explain to people why would
we need this architecture why we would
want a product
like our studio connect so we just built
our own
version of you know as close to our
studio connectors we
get we built uh in our studio pro server
we built a hosting environment for
training applications and markdown
applications
and we started converting some of the
existing projects we had
into r and deploying them through group
shining
you know we stood up i think we had a
git lab um that we installed on one of
the servers and started
really built the entire ecosystem to
show people how it worked and kind of
prove out
you know our vision of what this
cloud-based analytics system would look
like
it was pretty successful now fortunately
what we didn't do was sort of plan for
the long-term management of this
so we stood up the r studio server and
we
got people accounts we had all this we
had the poc we had
project managers we had all these things
right and then once it was a success
everyone said yeah this is successful
and then they sort of handed the keys
over to our team
while it was i mean it's certainly
interesting because
me and another person on my team started
actually
uh approving you know approving the
requests for licenses
and setting them up on the server and
you know writing bash code
to handle updates and all these things
um
does that really wasn't the best time
for our people so
now we've sort of hired some people to
who are full-time managers of the system
they can
if a compiler needs to be updated they
can update the compiler if
you know if we need to expand or buy
more space whatever they're sort of
managing this stuff
um it was a good problem to have became
very successful and
and it sort of overwhelmed us and how
much
work needs to be done to maintain and
add people
but in retrospect um it would have been
ideal if we would have
thought all this down ahead of time
the second thing we did that worked
really well was we went and found
all of the analytics people throughout
the company not just data scientists not
just people in i.t
people in supply chain people in sales
people in the regional finance offices
the people who are doing sort of amazing
things
often you know often in something like
excel or tableau
and we just gave them gave them accounts
we set up their connections they needed
you know
gave them a brief overview of how to get
get started and let them go
we're talking a lot of the it people
with this idea they you know they
weren't
they were terrible into it you know
there's always sort of concerns for
security and
you know managing access and doing that
but i think we knew it was the right
thing to do to just
get people using the tool i
attach myself to a project um building a
rather complex application in shiny sort
of a
crud tool that interacts with our
our promotional data
another member of our team actually
built our
you know at the beginning of covid built
the entire
covid tracking for the for our factories
which
anytime an employee um you know
either obviously contracts covet or or
as you know reports that they've been in
contact with someone
we needed to maintain this you know if
you think about a year ago
sort of the confusion around all this
like built the entire tool
built some security for it sort of did
all this in
in china and i think this product sold
to everyone that this is the
route to go
now unfortunately we didn't have any
user groups or
any connections between all these
separate people
so we we quickly had you know a lot of
you know a lot of searches on google on
on how to do things
and some inconsistency in the libraries
people were using and
we were managing the library centrally
so we'd get all these requests for
um you know depreciated libraries have
to
have to manage all these so what we're
trying to do now
is actually have uh you know a group of
people
who meet to share what they do and sort
of standardize some processes
not that we don't want people to you
know be innovative or anything like that
but
there's just sort of a lot of work uh
you know managing people doing
very similar things in in different ways
and then the final thing is we've really
really pushed the idea of having the
centralized analytics platform
that's cloud-based that if you want to
deliver content to someone it was
one place they could go to it was
web-based everyone could access it
if you remember sort of the push for the
cloud mobile api
uh mobile last year sort of dropped off
the radar i assume it's because everyone
was working at home
but the idea of the centralized platform
the cloud-based architecture
really enabled us to go through 2020
without
you know any real delays in the work we
were doing because we sort of had this
stood up
right at the beginning we worked through
a lot of the issues sort of in the
middle of 2020 but
having this enabled us to handle all
these new things obviously working uh
you know if you if anyone else is in
sort of the cpg business but
or i guess if anyone was shopping at a
grocery store you noticed this
there were massive supply constraints um
most likely a lot of promotions were
pulled
that were planned um the way we
allocated
our production was really to fill
shelves
uh versus anything else all this stuff
was sort of built in in our studio and
and delivered through connect
so everyone is sort of on board at this
point
unfortunately the people we
we didn't sort of bring into this
initial cohort
um were being asked to build things that
are
without without really knowing anything
about our
so i think this is you know another
problem of of success
sort of causing an issue
we're trying to rectify this now we're
you know we're really taking
uh katie will know i routinely emailed
her
throughout the year last year saying i
really wanted to make sure we
we got an education thing going entirely
my fault that it never
never really took off now we're very
very very
committed to doing this we want to
upskill tons of people we want to give
people these tools
we want to see what people can do um
even today we're going through sort of
sort of an architecture change i'm
i was talking to some consultants who
are managing migration of some things
from sas to r
and they'd sort of asked about um
like scheduling like batch jobs and i
took them through this
idea of like building in our markdown
file that that
you know runs on a schedule generates a
report
you know emails people sort of the
changes made into the system
i think when people started to see this
i mean they really see the power
now it's up to us to make sure they have
the capability
and i went really really fast because i
know we're behind
hopefully that gives enough time please
ask questions you're welcome to
email me or on linkedin however however
you can get a hold of me if you
if you want to talk more i left out a
lot of details on the architecture
because
i don't think you're supposed to put
your architecture up just in case
there's any competitors
but if anyone wants to uh you know talk
in depth please let me know
thank you
awesome thank you thank you so much
oh katie i'll let you go sorry
thank you phil i i think i think a lot
of the challenges that you
described are pretty common in in either
in fuller in pieces for a lot of folks
um uh so again i'll encourage folks to
put questions in the chat window
just for the sake of time because i'm
really eager as well
uh to have you hear what yohan chang um
has to say you hung joins us from
adco um and has a a great app that she's
chosen to spotlight with us today
hey i'm going to share my screen
can you see my screen now yes we can see
it
yes okay great
so
um so my name is johan chen my
background is actually in aerospace
engineering and statistics
and after graduation i had a great
opportunity to join the fantastic team
at echo and now i'm
the advanced analytics specialist at
global quality field
in appco so today
i will quickly go through
um give you an overview about our
company because that will help
you to understand our
challenges and the difficulties we are
facing right now
um because um i believe
most of you have ever you know
probably everyone has ever had kellogg's
product you know their food or the
flight
either airbus or boeing you know they
both use
pretty quick news engine so you sort of
has your customer experiences with their
products but i believe
probably no one has ever used our
products before i mean neither do i
but i believe many of you have had the
food
you know either plant or harvested
by our product so we are we are
a global leader in the design
manufactured and distribution for
agricultural solutions and we are also
the leader and experts in global farming
solutions
so these are the four big leading brands
we have for different type of
agriculture vehicles including tractors
rotators targeters and anything you
limit but we are also the only forward
product in company in agriculture
industry why i say that because we also
have a very
comprehensive granule protein
department which we own these five
brands
so you probably know gsi and also
cnba bra and other brands as well
so our values and missions stand on you
know
providing um sustainability
and good quality products to farmers and
also improving
farm incomes
so um just a quick overview to our
history
as you can see um echo is a pretty young
um company last year was our 30 years
anniversary
and we officially started in 1990s
and in the past 30 years actually we
have
acquired over 40 companies that's why
that's one of the the method we grow
this company so
fast and and not become so big and
during you know other
acquisition and you know it means
you have to also acquire
that company's data board as well it
means we can't
gather other people's data evolved into
our own system
that make our data actually very dirty
i mean more complex than you know the
the cfd turbulent flow
data i've ever handled before and that
actually caused a lot of
challenges to us especially for
agriculture even let's talk about
tractors
even you see different type of tractors
doesn't mean we can really just compare
them together
because we have tractors designed for
just maybe common uses
and also we have tractors designed for
vinyard we have tractors designed for
grants or for food
so how to standardize our
analysis tool to make sure
when we analyze our data when we analyze
our
our product quality we won't make
mistakes like comparing apples and
oranges together and
we can provide nice you know kpi for
everyone especially now
echo produce you know
133 000 vehicles per year
and we we have 43 manufacturing
locations
and in the past you know some of the
manufacturing locations were
joined by um acquisition
so it means each factories actually
has their habits their know-how so we
have to
understand you know what they have and
what they try to do
and also make sure when we standardize
this system
we can balance everything and we can try
to make everyone you know not only our
engineers happy but also make our
customers happy
so and by
2020 actually we have uh 3200
providers and our products and customers
are
you know spreading worldwide and we we
produce not only
you know tractors rotators terrigators
and different type of
you know or or grand storage we also
produce
you know green products as well so
this is about echo and now we're talking
about
what do we do with our what we choose
are and
what are are challenges so one of the
reason we choose our
or you can say we choose our studio and
our studio connect is because
it provides a very um
to me it's a very friendly environment
and also very nice flexibility
for us to customize any tools we want
um so our challenge
is you know leveraging data science to
supercharge
global quality control so let me use
this map
to go through our our design map so
to us in data you know in data science
field our
our wonderland is the the data pool
with puzzles which are you know the the
market dynamics
product qualities customers experiences
and so forth
and our adventure starts at the moment
we first examine
our data and try to find a way out right
that's
what alex try to do and when we
discover and explore our market dynamics
then we start to
do our product design that's the first
phase of our
rnb and then we do tech development
try to finish r d and then once we
finish up
we start to make products and then we do
test and after test we deliver our
products
to our customers and after a while
we start to receive feedback and like
all the companies we got angel customers
who love our products
for all reasons and sometimes we have
you know um
just you know unhappy
customers yeah i won't say crazy
customers but unhappy customers and and
when they find out you know that the
products and other students they expect
it
they file plans or you know the products
fail too fast we receive plans
so less builders drives better
customer experiences and our goal is to
make everybody happy and try to improve
our customer experiences
so uh some people may ask what do we do
during r d because for you know one
chan in quality control is r d
and in automobile industry or in
aerospace industry i
am actually in agricultural industry we
all use
doe which is designed experiment a lot
but for agriculture we most of the time
we use that for
like do some scientific way to to to do
plants
but it's it's a little bit hard to use
design of experiment method
in agriculture machine building because
unlike
automobile you can predict which
environment your car may experience
right
i mean the road we know the average
quality of road
we know we have highway we have just
regular road or sometimes pretty muddy
and we know traffic light and we know
that at
probably average driver
habits but for a good culture we have
very very you know all varieties of
um geography characteristics
you know that the machine could be used
for very very cold
environment or very hot environment or
very muddy environment
and also different plants and
we cannot just design one harvester for
all type of plants and also we have
different
planets so it's a little bit like
too many elements to to do the oe plus
when automobile industry do
test driving for their new product they
can build their own campus
and just do test writing but to us when
we do
our test driving it's either plan
something or harvest something and when
you harvest out
the plants it means you've got nothing
left to do
more experiments so so that's
one of our challenges and also dilemma
so it means
for our product design and technology
develop
doe method is pretty limited so it
depends a lot
in the you know clan
analysis so one solution to us is to
develop
a centralized tool providing information
and comprehensive insights of data
analysis
so well the so we have several methods
and the first method is to to
standardize
our um performance measurements such as
claim rate and repair frequency
and everybody has to use the same method
to
to to to do the math otherwise we cannot
put all the numbers on the same page
and also we have to use the same way to
do cost and usage
our analysis and also we have to
we have different type of kpis to to
measure different type of things
and the second thing is we recently
start to integrate telemetry data which
means we can
monitor our machines
life and we sort of i think we receive
data from each machine um sometimes
every five seconds sometimes every 10
seconds
and what does it mean it means we got
different type of code and when we
receive the code
doesn't mean the machine failed
it could be something it could be
nothing so we need to try to understand
you can say the the language machine try
to tell us
and also we need to set up a threshold
like
if we analyze telemetry data
every single time means every 10 seconds
this huge amount of information and
maybe
too much if we simple threshold like
okay we only
get data like every 60 seconds maybe
that's enough or
all we have to do just every 100 seconds
so that's the part we are developing and
try to
figure out what's the best way to set up
threshold code and focus on you know
different
brand different machine and probably
under different user environment
and once we figure it out we can build
an alarm system to forecast
failure means we notice okay
some code keep coming out means some
part
will fill up soon so we can
notice our farmer say hey uh maybe the
o-ring in your engine
which part is going to you know you need
to replace that
otherwise it will fail maybe in the next
10 usage hours
something like that so farmers can
replace that before
the machine fails so the farmers won't
you know
got nothing to do and just with
with the time you know for for
for his work and and then the third
thing is
um to build a predictive
model um to predict failure rate
um here we use weapon analysis
so some people probably heard about
weibo before because it's a very mature
method has been applied for applied in
manufacturing industry for i think since
1970s
but in the past 50 years actually weibo
analysis has been improved and modified
into different forms
and we applied this method over 20 years
ago
and we kept modifying that and in our
latest um
tool we built um in
uh one is you can say empirical method
another one is based on maximum
likelihood method because
it it it depends on which way we
collect the data and use some different
scenario
and the last thing is you know other
data source analytics tensions
and um like for every time we
we receive a clamp it comes with one
global console card
so one main part fill sometimes come
with
you know very few replace parts or
hundreds of replacements
are they related can we find find out
some patterns that's also
you know our our job we try to figure it
out
so the major challenge like i just you
know i said a few minutes ago
first is dirty data because during
um mna we kept receiving
data from different companies and and
each company has its own
habits to collect the data to store the
data
so we have to put them into our central
el system
so when he received that and then
after you know a while i got
everything actually still very dirty so
we have to figure out a way to to clean
it without hurting
you know important information inside
the data
and then is the limited sample size and
like i said
um in agriculture
um we won't be able to do that type of
um a lot of tests like automobile
industry do so in certain way
our sample size is limited but doesn't
mean that the data size
is limited we got huge data science just
the sample size somehow it's limited
and also we have a brick unpredictable
product usage um in
even it's the same product and but when
we sell it to different
let's say in the united states but
different states
and different areas different farmers
have different
um usage you know preference so
and and also they probably use them for
different purposes
so the product usage actually is a
little bit unpredictable
and and also um this tool would build
has to
be you know um
work with um big data and live data we
have to monitor
telemetry data congregate everything
together also
our users hope everything can be
calculated in real time
so it means we need something to help us
to
you know organize everything and every
time we choose different filters
and the filters has to be fully dynamic
we can get different results and the
results have to be reliable
so those are our main challenges and
that's the
main reason we choose to work with r
and also our studio connect because
after we build the user interface
we you know we store everything on
our sql server and
all we have to do to send the message to
you know script 2 to sql
and then tell sql which part of the data
we need and
if it's small amount of data maybe just
a few seconds if it's a huge amount of
data maybe up to 20 to 30 seconds
but still acceptable but another
important thing is this tool can be
used for you know by multiple users at
the same time
so before we
start working with r this is our first
generation tool we call ida standing as
the
famous opera you know princess aida and
this tool was built under tableau and
tableau is a very beautiful tool for
presentation but we
did have a lot of hard time to work with
that when we
you know the data got bigger bigger and
bigger plus it's
not easy to integrate some complicated
math algorithms to copy everything in
real time
so eventually we just compromised
we pre-calculate a lot of things
so even everything we pre-calculated you
know
every day but precalculation means
we have very limited permutation
combination
we cannot really get what users really
want
so eventually we go to r
and build this tool we call that
analytics
and this is a simplified version and
this is the main cockpit as you can see
and i'm going to just give you a tour
to analyticals
so this is the home page and um and
don't worry you won't be able to use
that
because you have to have our vpn 2
access to this website
and this is just a quick demo to you um
[Music]
so like i say everything is dynamic
means um if i choose you know
different type of machine it will go
through and this is default so it means
we got
all the manufacturing locations together
and uh
here oh i won't just do what i say
tractors
i don't want you know harvesting you
know different type of
implements or generators and then we
have a lot of manufacturing locations
and
this is my dummy data
one of my dummy data and i got so many
dummy tractors here let's just do
um because i know we are running out of
time a little bit
so just do something simple
and here i choose analysis level you
know from
global support number and to failure
area to failure defect
and actually this is the highest level
and and this is the sub area and this is
the
sub sub area and in the past we usually
just focus on global cost of our number
and but then we figure out sometimes you
know
it's it's not about global cost apart
it's more about
some area just easy to get failed so we
try to you know
use different way to figure out um
what's the prediction uh sorry the the
failure rate
and using different ways to evaluate our
rival analysis
so first we got like data overall
information
and you can monitor your data by you
know
choosing this is a pivot table and this
is
our other indicator and this is our
alarm list
showing us this something like summary
and we
probably want to go from for example
we always try to know what's our failure
rate a at our
target hour and previously we said our
target hour is 1 000
um engine hour and say at 1 000
the failure rate for these two already
be 100
and probably reach this number way
before 1000
and we usually want to keep this number
you know
as small as we want and this is the
forward
information and but the wiper plot
actually looks like this
okay so if we choose global culture part
number
you can see this one is about host and
um
we also want to see maybe we got okay
that's the only
host we got and we got air pressure
and we want to see what's going on here
and for air pressure
it could be let's assume we got a lot of
points here
and only a few you know in
low usage hour we may just you know for
some time we probably want to see what's
going on when we just cut up our data
because some of them
could be outliers and you probably
noticed the number changed
and this is the total failure number
also change and the way we calculate the
the total machines covered by you know
this global causal part number was
sometimes also changed because
it has to be covered by the
manufacturing date range
so beta is very important because if
this number
you know equal i mean larger than one it
means
it basically were not by time so we
always hope
this you know
um can be you know larger than one okay
and uh
sorry rachel uh i couldn't see i see you
raise your hand but
oh sorry i was trying to give a one
minute warning and
no problem easiest way possible
and um yeah and also you can download
data
and everything and very fast and these
these are just more more charts and like
heat map
everything and you can you know monitor
things by
different way and uh different region
that's it and uh also one thing
important to us
is we can just download after you know
selecting everything we can also use the
second layer filter to
um this is a design to let them probably
they want to filter down a few things
and they can download the report
and this is the example of the report i
already generated because i know we
probably will
you know go out of time
something like that so overall
this is um the tool we built
and actually there were a lot more
functions for like predictions
and analysis but today uh we got
a little bit running out of time so i'm
going to stop right here
awesome thank you so much you hung it
was great to to see the application as
well
i'm trying to scroll through and see if
there were some questions there because
i'd love to stay on and
ask a few live questions to all three of
our speakers if anybody can stay on with
us
but again we will post the q a and the
link to the recording
on the meetup page and on
community.ourstudio.com
um but you hung one of the questions i
see
for you was um i'm trying
it's scrolling down here uh if there
were alternatives to
weeble that you were using and jeff just
mentioned that
he maybe missed a few of those
uh alternatives about what sorry
i'm not sure the question
were there were there any alternatives
to libel methods that you were that you
looked at or did you just look at using
bible uh
yes uh because basically
um well
actually one thing i didn't have time to
show is actually there uh we were
focusing on different ways to exploring
weibo because like i say there are
several different ways to build a weibo
data but uh so far we've tried like
three different ways to build that but
other than
weibo we also try like um
if i mean time dependent gaussian
process which
i'm familiar with and also um
other type of um time series models
there are varieties but
they all have to be um
i notice if i want to get a good result
i have to utilize a lot of telemetry
data
or you can set life monitor data because
because
those data will provide not only
um the information from clan
because when we receive a claim means
something broke and we collect
everything like usage hours and all type
of situations of that certain machine
but live data also providing us
information
like that when the machine is still
healthy so
before we officially um
release other tools we have to clear out
telemetry data
and that's one of the challenge because
currently we're facing
um first is the amount of the data issue
we try to find out what's the best way
to set up a threshold
otherwise it's a little bit overwhelmed
and probably won't
make our predictive model sensitive
enough
that's one problem yeah so there are
other issues like uh
what code we receive from telemetry data
we should use to get into
our predictive model so that's why
some predict model we haven't you know
fully explored
and also we haven't released this to
this tool yet
thank you you hang i think most of the
questions
to brandon and phil were maybe answered
in the chat but if there are any
other questions that you'd like to ask
them live i'm
happy to have you post them there or
just ask out loud and unmute yourself
or if you're thinking of other questions
i will go for one more for for you hung
i see brandon had just asked what were
the reports you showed
at the end share directly with the
customer
the machinery owner um this is our
insight
inside tool so the reports are to our
pcr
and engineers and also our manufacturing
location
factories and for customers as i
know we have another system working with
salesforce
generating different type of reports
so you know some information
we only show to our people
so
great thank you are there any other
questions that we missed
oh one one other question from josh you
hung did you encounter any internal
conflict or
internal politics from using shiny in
place of tableau
yes we
actually
i don't want to use the word fight but
we did
uh spend quite a while to
convey to to let it department be you
know convinced that
shiny is a good tool to be used because
previously they really really want us to
stay with tableau
forever and then we we developed
some cases including i already spent
time to
build weibo um actually two different
type of rivals
inside tableau to connect to live data
and
show them the turn runtime differences
and ones like
five to ten seconds the most another one
is
um forget about it so very soon they
realize you know tableau is good we
still use that for a long scenario
just for for this type of case we really
need to switch to
shining yeah so yes we
we did encounter some
internal conflicts but we solve it
and not everybody happy